- Political courage is
doing the right thing
and when you are tested to
stand up, and when it's hard,
and it's tough you stand
and do the right thing.
Not only did he change those
monuments but he also changed
an attitude and for
the first time I think,
he had an epiphany, I
think as a young mayor,
a young man he was probably
not aware of just how
offensive Robert E. Lee's statue was,
but to a lot of people, to
young people, black people,
white people even it really bothered them.
It bothered them a lot.
And so it's going to take
like Mayor Landrieu, and other
people I believe at the local level,
where people live, where
people work, where people play,
where people pray, and
where they love each other;
the right to love who they want to love
is gonna take I think the mayor's
of this nation to make us really great.
(engaging music)